right now in almost two dozen states across
the country, Republicans who control state
legislatures are working on legislation.
We just saw one in Texas a couple of days
ago that would make it a felony to protest
an oil pipeline or a chemical plant or an
oil refinery or a refinery.
They want to make protesting any of these
so called infrastructure projects as they
call them a felony.
Now, the law that just passed the house in
Texas, uh, originally it was going to make
it punishable by up to 20 years in prison.
But they decided maybe that was a little too
harsh and they bumped it down to now if this
law passes, you're only gonna get 10 years
in prison for protesting the placement of
an oil pipeline.
What's happening here is that they're trying
to argue that these protesters come along
and they interrupt economic activity or they
damage critical pieces of fossil fuel infrastructure.
Now I understand we don't like these pipelines
and I do not advocate damage to them of any
kind.
However, a peaceful protest is allowed by
the constitution.
Just because you don't like it doesn't mean
you can pass a law at the state level saying,
you can't do this.
That's unconstitutional.
We have the right to peaceably assemble here
in the United States.
You cannot take that away just because you
want to keep flooding this country with fossil
fuels and toxic chemicals.
And yet that is exactly what these states
are working on.
And let me go through some of the list here.
I already mentioned Texas.
Here we have Oklahoma individuals who protest
pipelines can now be smacked with a $100,000
fine and 10 years in prison.
This, according to the Sierra Club, Louisiana
says activists who make unauthorized entry
of a critical infrastructure such as oil pipelines,
face a punishment of up to five years in prison
and a $1,000 fine.
North Dakota last March passed a law under
which interfering with pipeline construction
becomes a felony punishable by up to five
years in prison and a $10,000 fine.
And groups conspiring with such protests could
be criminal criminally liable for 10 times
that amount.
So $100,000 fine for anybody who conspires
with these protesters.
You know, perhaps a nonprofit, an environmental
organization that sets up these protests.
See, they're not just going after the protesters
themselves.
They're working on ways written into these
laws to defund the organizations who help
organize these events and these protests.
That's phase two.
First you take away everybody's First Amendment
right saying you cannot come and protest this
pipeline.
And the second is we're going to bankrupt
and punish the organizations who are helping
people organize these protests.
That's a double whammy at this point.
There's even more here and it's, it's absolutely
discussing, uh, officials in South Dakota
are arguing that there are limits to free
speech when protest comes into conflict with
economic interests.
I don't remember seeing that in the first
amendment of the U s constitution.
I, I don't think it said that our right to
peacefully assemble is limited as long as
it does not, you know, interfere with economic
activities.
Other than that you're good to go, but hey,
you do anything that might disrupt the flow
of commerce than no, suddenly you can't do
it.
That's not in the constitution.
And that's one of the reason why these laws
are likely to fail.
But again, this is not the first time we've
seen a slew of laws come into play.
At the same time we saw shortly after Charlottesville,
Republican controlled legislature is we're
trying to make it illegal for people to protest.
You tried to limit where they could or could
not gather.
And this wasn't in response to the horrible
people in Charlottesville.
This was in response to the people who were
protesting the bad people.
All of this boils down to the fact that they
want to take away our constitutional rights.
That's what every one of these laws is designed
to do.
Otherwise, they wouldn't feel the need to
do it.
Okay.
But every one of these is likely to get struck
down in court.
Even if it goes up to one of the most conservative
justices in this country, they understand
too, regardless of their ideology, that you
can not infringe on that particular, right,
because if you do, then what's going to happen
the next time somebody challenges the Second
Amendment right?
You know, and says, well, wait a minute.
You've already dismantled the first amendment.
Why don't we start dismantling the second
one too that would actually save lives here
in the United States?
I don't think that's ever going to happen,
but it's something that these conservatives
need to have in their back pocket so that
they understand that at all times you come
after the amendments that matter, then you're
going to see people coming after the only
amendment that you seem to care about.
But nonetheless, we should all be upset about
this regardless of your ideology.
They are trying to strip us of our constitutional
rights and that is not something that is ever
okay in this country.
We're going to take a quick break, but if
you want even more from me, you can follow
me on Twitter at fair and balanced.
You can find me on Instagram handle
Facebook at fair and balanced.
I am Farron cousins from ring of fire sitting
in for David Pakman.
We'll be right back.